now the manchester bombing inquiry
reported earlier this week douglas
murray has written this column about it
this week and he joins me now douglas
you've been following this for quite
some time
what jumped out at you in this report
well we learned a number of things
uh the inquiry finds
uh the number of occasions on which
uh salman abadi the suicide bomber
in question on the night of the ariana
grande concert
in 2017 the inquiry finds a number of
occasions when he could have been
identified
and should have been identified could
have been stopped
and should have been stopped now
inquiries like this seems to me
having read a lot of them in my time
always are going to find
faults it's inevitable there will be
intelligence faults
there will be security faults human
error
and more and and this is no different to
that extent
uh there's human error of a staggering
kind
the most obvious being uh two uh um
members of the police who went for a
kebab half an hour away
uh when they were meant to be at the
venue and then ate their dinner
in a secure room and
basically weren't doing their job uh
there were things like that but as i say
in my column this week
they're really disturbing thing about
this
inquiry by sir john saunders is
something that is revealed by a single
witness
who worked for one of the security
companies at the manchester arena on the
night
and can you tell us a bit more about
this was kyle lawler the
who is at the time 18 year old security
guard paid four pounds 26 per hour
yeah um i mean something should be said
about this by the way which is before
serious services you know these security
companies as we know from previous
incidents they had a sort of veneer of
security
but basically if anything serious
happens uh um
most of the time these companies are not
fit for purpose
uh so they add a sort of feeling of
security without actually providing it
and what i'm about to say as i say in
the piece i don't criticize
mr lawler for this he was a young man
and
i can't imagine what he has on his
conscience in relation to this but he
was at least
honest to the inquiry uh kyle lawler
says that like a number of other people
on the night
he noticed salman abedi he couldn't have
failed to notice him in a way because
salman abadi was hanging around
for more than an hour and a quarter by
the entrance exits
of the building he was inside the
building he was struggling
with a 32 kilogram rucksack
which we now know contained the bomb
and uh kyle lawler was one of the people
on the night who
noticed him thought there was something
up uh and he says
specifically that what he noticed about
mr a baby going backwards and forward
struggling with
his extremely heavy uh backpack
was he said he had a nervous reaction
uh whenever anyone looked at him and
seemed
fidgety now that's
uh not the important thing the important
thing is what kyle lawler said
after this he stated to the inquiry
that he was fearful of identifying mr
abadi
he said he was fearful of being branded
a racist
and feared that he would be in trouble
if he got it wrong
and as i say in my piece uh
one shouldn't blame kyle lawler first it
is
perhaps inevitable some people would but
i admire the fact he was honest about it
he was honest about the fact that
actually in modern britain
quite understandably he made the
decision
that if you see something you shouldn't
say something you should shut up
because there's far more to risk by
saying something
and being accused of being a racist than
there is of not saying something
and the bomb going off that's a
calibration that modern britain
has indoctrinated people into
for many many years and you can't just
indoctrinate
people out of it when i was reading the
report i was really quite struck by the
kind of strength of character that carl
lawler must
have i mean i'm not sure in his
situation he was somebody who i think
learned his trade via an online course
so
he had been given very little training
no real experience
yet it would have been very easy for him
just to pretend that he'd seen
nothing to not have anybody publicly
blame him for missing something because
i'm sure some people will say well if
only he'd blown the whistle
of course he's putting himself up there
for criticism
i imagine though he's doing this to make
a rather important point
that a lot of people in his position
would hesitate
to blow the whistle for the reasons that
he gives that
you might be branded discriminatory and
i guess the same is true for anybody
who's in the security industry because
when you stop somebody who looks
suspicious i guess you do need to ask
yourself
am i being biased here to what extent is
racial profiling
morally acceptable when it comes to
stopping people going through airports
through other
shopping arenas another this is a
dilemma we've had ever since 9-1-1
that's right in fact of course as you
know and we have an entire industry now
in britain as across the rest of the
western world
which says that we've not just got
biases but they're inbuilt in us they're
implicit in us
and we have to eradicate them we have to
question our alleged biases
we've got to do double takes all the
time
mentally this is a whole industry that
the the
vast swathes of government the private
sector and others have imbibed
and this isn't the reason why salman
obedie got into it
that's just one further manifestation of
the problem
that kyle lawler has so sadly put his
finger on
as you say you know fraser you know this
is a young guy
who underwent very little training he
said that he had no particular knowledge
there was going to be an incident on the
night which is true he couldn't have
known that
uh he could have known they should have
been told that the terrorism threat in
the uk was severe at the time it was
only shortly
after the attack in westminster uh
before of course the attack on london
bridge
but the the the terrorism uh
risk status was at severe but
again it's people much more senior
than this very junior online trained
uh security officer who i think have to
take some responsibility for getting
britain into the position
that you can't honestly identify
somebody who you think might be a
suicide bomber
for fear of basically detonating your
own career
and i mentioned in my piece several
examples of
high profile police officers in greater
manchester
who set the scene for that because as i
mentioned in the piece
one year almost exactly before the
manchester arena bombing
there was a test
exercise at the manchester shopping
center
in which the local um security services
the local
emergency services trained for basically
an eventuality
uncannily like the one on the night in
the manchester arena
it was to test the preparedness of the
first responders of the emergency
services
and the whole occasion was marred by a
single detail
which is that the actor playing the
suicide bomber on that occasion
at the manchester shopping center
shouted allahu akbar
or allah is greatest before detonating
the
fake device that then led to the play
act and the
attempt to prepare the emergency
services the whole exercise
was um forgotten about and massively
uh marred by this fact because there was
an immediate backlash
against the uh whole scenario
for the person playing the suicide
bomber shouting allahu akbar
and therefore totally appallingly
outrageously unforgivably linking the
possibility of a suicide bombing
with islamist extremism and all
of the local community leaders went off
on this
how dare you make this connection and
the local police
people like the greater manchester
police and crime commissioner tony lloyd
all
apologized for it they said it's
outrageous it's it's
marred and otherwise successful event
and
i think uh tony lloyd the greater
manchester police and crime commissioner
said
that this didn't add anything to the
event the shouting of allah
it just has the potential he said to
undermine the great community relations
we have
in greater manchester so this is the
position that people like
kyle lawler found themselves on the
night that there was a real-time suicide
bomber
really standing in front of them under
their noses struggling with a 32
kilogram
bomb they had been told by every major
policeman
in the area that you should do nothing
to link these things and that is why we
had effectively tr
trained people trained people out of
identifying
what was under their noses right at the
time as you say douglas the
threat level was number three and but
it's right now it's number two
substantial it seems in the last 20
years there's hardly been many times
where there hasn't been
a kind of a threat and yet so so you can
understand why the security guard didn't
quite know what
they wouldn't have been really expecting
one of these attacks but you also have
to work
wonder just how much you can really
expect
out of relatively junior people who are
i mean you know
you could see probably somebody senior
perhaps a soldier or something might be
able to
to work that thing out but even the
metropolitan police have had lots of
problems stop and search
they've been accused of racially
profiling black londoners theresa may
told them to stop it and it can be a
very difficult balance
to to get right because if you you go
too much and of course you end up
with a system where people of um asian
or middle eastern outlook get asked for
their id even in the house of commons
here a lot more than
than white so you can see why there is
concern of
of taking this a bit too far in certain
circumstances
well what happens here is that the
balance
swings too far in one direction
and we have to accept the fact that in
2017
uh the profile of a
suicide bomber at a pop concert
pretty much exactly fitted the profile
of salman abadi
a young radicalized male of
north african or middle eastern descent
this was pretty much the the likely
person it was not a woman it was not
a white woman uh it was a particular
profile and you might say well
you know you've got to check 20 people
who don't fit the profile in order to
allow yourself
to check one person who does fit the
profile
but as we saw on the night in manchester
these sorts of games are ones you can
treat yourself
to until it gets really serious and the
manchester arena bombing
was an unbelievable event and it should
never be forgotten
it's been to some extent i've always
said slightly brushed over i have to say
when you consider the amount of
attention that some
outrages get the extraordinary way in
which it's sort of been
you know brushed over almost from the
beginning we had the whole don't look
back in anger sort of thing about it uh
this whole don't draw any lessons out
from it
and by the way there are still lessons
we don't know we just don't know
answers to very major questions even
after the saunders report i
i give an example in my column this week
of something we still don't know
salman a baby's parents came to the uk
in the 1990s the father was a member of
the libyan islamic fighting group which
uh subsequently joined al qaeda
uh uh joined up with al-qaeda as an
affiliate the father of salman abedi
was in the libyan islamic fighting group
and they fell out with colonel gaddafi
in the 1990s very sadly
these people fell out with each other
and so britain
gave sanctuary to the baby parents and
that's how young salman abadi was born
in the uk he was born because we gave
his parents asylum and uh salman abadi
and his utterly reprehensible brother
uh um were the gifts we got in britain
for this i still can't find
after all this time and even after this
review any explanation from
any official in the uk as to why this
happened
why did we give them asylum what did we
gain
from it what exactly other than two
appalling sons did they give to this
country or bring to this country
nothing nada zilch and yet
nobody in authority has ever yet
given an explanation for this let alone
been held accountable for this
and this is one of the things i still
find absolutely astonishing in the
british discussion of this
we always get in the uk as i've written
at spectator many times
we always get these sort of slightly
fake debates you know
to my mind stop and search is a
relatively comfortable debate
compared to some of the other debates
that we ought to have
why was it that the obedie family were
in the uk
why was it that in the london bridge
attack only weeks later
two of the three attackers had as far as
i can understand
no legitimate cause for being in the uk
one who lied about his nationality was
found out to have lied and then
anyway wasn't deported from the uk and
the other was somebody who claimed
asylum from pakistan a few years ago
why was the uk giving asylum to somebody
from pakistan in the late 1990s or early
2000s
why was it that when somebody pretends
to be a moroccan turns out to be a
libyan
hacks at women's throats on london
bridge while shouting
that nobody's much interested in what
he's doing here in the first place
and all the crappy security supremos get
on to the comfortable debates
they get onto things like oh to what
extent is online radicalization an issue
because it's so much easier to talk
about these crappy
third-rate issues of what you can do
with google
and and so on it's so much easier than
just those
basic elementary questions there has
never been an asking of those elementary
questions
there still hasn't been and i think it
points
to the failures we still have even after
all these years in the uk
of properly discussing what is a serious
security threat
that's ongoing but one potential answer
there is that we gave him
i don't know the details but at the time
colonel gaddafi wasn't exactly running a
benign regime you could certainly see
why
um somebody might be fleeing in fear of
their life from that regime
like most european countries you can
definitely see that you can definitely
see that so
that's what you want to see in the
country that question is relatively easy
to answer
that that question should be relatively
easy to answer but there will be
probably thousands of other libyan
refugees who've
led constructive lives into the country
i'm not at all sure
that the british taxpayers money
is uh well spent in giving asylum
to jihadists who've fallen out with
other jihadists
i mean it's possible we could decide to
be the great uh
convening center some people would argue
we have been in recent decades
for the sort of you know intra-jihadist
fallout community but i don't think
that's what the british
public ever wanted i know it's something
we were never asked about
uh so so so yes there are explanations
and i'd like to hear them and i'd like
them to be stressed
by the officials i'd like them to
justify their decisions i'd like them to
explain to the british public
why it seems there are so many cases of
people who've gone on to commit
terrorist acts
who as far as i can see gave britain
nothing
and took in the case of salman abadi 22
young lives
[Music]
you